i mean like this was someone who was one
of the most successful in her business
sort of a math nerd kind of a quiet kid
from canada
all of a sudden not only was she fired
summarily without any benefits and
without any severance
uh lost all the benefits that she'd been
accruing she couldn't get a job anywhere
else in the industry
because her name is now radioactive
because of these media lies that have
been told about her
i mean i think it was cbs even rained
with a story saying she had been
convicted
at one point and i was like they give me
the case in it being she was not only
was it all dismissed it was dismissed
with prejudice
with no deal no diversion no nothing
this was an
acknowledgement by the city of new york
that it was a complete mistake but the
allegations were against her
you know you mentioned uh related to
defunding the police and how in kenosha
that just that we've seen this in so
many of these cities that they're just
the
law enforcement is not doing what it's
supposed to do as you know i'm still
here in crazy
la we've got a uh d.a
this guy george gascon bernie backed d.a
middle-aged white guy who got rid of our
first female black d.a not that i care
about that but i thought you know the
identity politics
people do in any event he is doing
exactly what he did in san francisco
before which is exactly what chessa
bodine is doing in san francisco now
where they are just choosing not to
prosecute
certain crimes now i'm not a legal
expert but this is at this point this is
seeming criminal
to me like when they when they swear
themselves or when they get sworn in
it's to defend the laws and they're just
picking which laws they're not defending
do they need to be sued i mean there's
recalls in place but
is this not just like the most obvious
dereliction of duty
i think there should be more legal
remedies our current courts make it
almost impossible to ever sue
prosecutors
but it's like the texas sheriff suing
biden over refusal to enforce
immigration laws
the same thing because what they're
really doing is they're weaponizing a
criminal class it's kind of like early
1920s russia that the immediate the
initial stage of the soviet revolution
they often weaponized the criminal class
to side with them in the uh the ongoing
civil war that took place post 1917.
that's what they're saying kind of doing
here it's kind of what they did with the
black panthers in the late 60s early 70s
people don't know how much they were
embedded with drug dealers in criminal
operations
the thought process was this could be
our own political street army
uh allowing them to it sort of extend
their political power like it's
like escape from l.a might soon be a
documentary rather than just a film
but that's the name of my documentary
and deservedly so i mean because this is
insane
what's taking place i mean when you when
people can't even go into a group why
would you even buy anything anymore
under
a thousand bucks you're walking in you
see somebody walk in steal a bunch of
stuff and walk right out
this is just insanity this but what does
it promote it promotes disrespect
for the law what that produces is 1970s
level crime problems
and now politically that almost always
leads to a backlash
but in the interim a lot of
working-class people are the primary
people to suffer it's not the
west side beverly hills crowd that's
going to suffer it's the south central
and east l.a folks who are going to
suffer right so to be clear
right now in new york city because of
their ridiculous d.a you are allowed to
jump the turnstile so if you are
paying to get on the subway you're
basically a sucker we're saying hey
why are you paying just uh get on your
good high tops and jump that thing and
then here in la or san francisco
you are now allowed to trespass i think
it's 800
that you're allowed to steal from a
store so i always tell people you get a
playstation
five with four games you can't get five
games then you're over the threshold
then you can be in trouble
but it's like you're encouraging people
to break the law basically
and i would have more respect for them
if they said we'll prosecute anybody who
steals less than two thousand
but let anybody off who probably steals
more than ten thousand because then they
would be
down on rodeo drive but instead they're
basically asking like i have a
a client that's a mexican-american shop
owner that owns a little grocery stores
and throughout uh east l.a they're the
number ones who are
people victimized by this this doesn't
help working-class people this
hurts working-class honest people and
and rewards the criminal class
for the benefit of a political class and
that's why it's it's very dangerous but
it's politics is not even what they
pretended to be so what about
when we see democrats i mean i think
kamala harris actually
as a as a candidate it was before the
election had
taken place she was actually helping uh
fund some of these antifa people get out
of jail in minneapolis and some other
places
uh they are breaking the laws but for
some reason antifa is still on twitter
and everywhere else you know trump's
gone but they're everywhere
and that we actually have politicians
that are raising money
to help criminals that burn down stores
and you know attack cars on the street
uh to get out of jail yeah i mean it's
it's
extraordinary the last time we had
anything like this was late 1960s
when you had people in bed with the
black panthers in bed with actual
weather
underground in bed with a wide range of
you know there was like a different
revolutionary name every other week
people forget the crips you know
actually likes the committee for
revolution or whatever
i mean it was smart you're a local gang
and you're like oh we just rebrand we
rebrand as political
and now now we can steal stuff and kill
people and everything's okay it's kosher
but that's the same we brought back that
mindset
it was a disaster last time i don't know
anybody believe it's gonna be anything
other than a disaster this time
what kind of backlash do you think we're
going to see on this stuff
well if the 1970s or any preview you're
going to see dirty harry style backlash
you're going to see i mean like jd
vance's grand grandmother
her hero was dirty harry because of
growing up in that politically that's
why she had that 44
next door even when she couldn't
physically lift it you know later on in
life
so i think that's the kind of mindset
you're going to see you're going to see
more and more people
and i hope they don't go too far i hope
people were met you know civil rights
are important those are sometimes
violated by police actors
and sometimes in the 70s people were so
mad at the lawlessness
that they green lit some abusive
behaviors i think we need to find the
right balance in countering what's
taking place by the left currently do
you think it's possible that the cities
just aren't going to work anymore
like that like new york city for example
where i lived for most of my adult life
20 years i
loved loved loved loved new york city if
you can make it there you can make it
anywhere like
i think everyone until these last couple
years i would say that everyone in
america
should live there for a little while
just to get a taste of that thing but
the idea of being there now where at any
given moment
they can attack you on the street if
you're sitting at a restaurant or they
can break into the store
or hop the subway thing or the litany of
other things going on like
that maybe city life in a political
environment like this
just doesn't work well just look at my
client amy cooper
because the background you're describing
is the context they failed to include in
the media coverage
she's just out to help her dog run and
they'd shut down the dog runs in the
name of kovitz somehow
so the only place she could help get her
dog run to even get outside
during this lockdown era uh last summer
was
in the park and so she's by herself
early in the morning in the park
and then suddenly somebody jumps her
says that they got some you know little
treats for her dog
which is what scare anybody particularly
a young single woman in a city
particularly in the environment of what
was happening in new york at the time
where crime was skyrocketing
and everything else and she reacts by
just wanting to call police
and then she's blamed she's demonized
she loses her job
she has to leave the country she's
blacklisted from employment
and originally she was criminally
prosecuted until i got the prosecutor to
dismiss all charges
that's reality of life in new york city
what went from being
a dream went for someone like her a
quiet
you know a you know kid on the spectrum
uh to being an utter nightmare right
so that case which we we also covered
that one i mean there's video basically
where she's telling the guy to get away
from her but of course the media framed
its surprise surprise
as if she's a white supremacist and this
nice black man just approached her
to play with the dog and everything else
now obviously some of that stuff will
work out but
when someone like her gets fired from
their job
from something like that what what is
the legal recourse that they have
because it had nothing to do with
anything she did
obviously at the office and completely
demonized i mean like this was someone
who was one of the most successful in
her business
sort of a math nerd kind of a quiet kid
from canada all of a sudden not only was
she fired summarily without any benefits
and without any severance
i lost all the benefits that she'd been
accruing she couldn't get a job anywhere
else in the industry
because her name is now radioactive
because of these media lies that have
been told about her
i mean i think it was cbs even rain with
a story saying she had been convicted
at one point i was like the give me the
case end up being she was not only was
it all dismissed it was dismissed with
prejudice
with no deal no diversion no nothing
this was an acknowledgement by the city
of new york
that they it was a complete mistake what
the allegations were against her
because the truth came out she had
talked to the cops at the scene
she had clarified everything without any
question or controversy
what they didn't know is that first time
when she's on the phone they couldn't
hear her the phone was breaking up which
if you understand that that's why she's
panicking she's like there's nobody
coming to rescue me
and as to your point is to that guy the
week before when he did the same thing
to an african-american man that may
almost beat him up i mean because i mean
that was that response but you know the
but it gives you a sense when you live
in that kind of environment where
overnight you can feel like you're in
kafka's the trial
then the the in the world in ripped
by crime and lockdowns you know new york
city looks like
escape from new york john carpenter
instead of new york of dreams you know
new york the big apple
new york uh you know sleepless in
seattle kind of new york right well
that's also the thing it's like
people were so hyper racialized right
now to think about race all the time to
realize that everyone's got a camera to
think
that someone's coming to get you because
you know crime is jumping that everyone
is a little bit jumpy
but but for the average person that sees
that i think what they think is
oh i'm never going to speak up about
anything because i don't want to lose my
job
what would you what advice would you
give to people relative to keeping their
jobs but still being able to speak up
because that's probably like the number
one question i get at this point i don't
want to lose my job
yeah you know what's interesting is you
know michael malus has a version of
curse them with your yes sirs
like figure out whatever their
conspiracy theories are about you and
play into them
right and then they'll be even more
terrified and whatnot so
there's a lot that's the old ralph
ellison phrase curse them with your yes
sirs from uh invisible man
so i think there's a i think for each
person i don't impose on anybody an
obligation to be a hero
you don't have to go out and make a
noble stand if you feel like you're in a
position where you can
then i encourage people to do so and
lawyers like me will help bring suits
for them
we're challenging mass mandates we're
challenging vaccine mandates
we're challenging these unconstitutional
firings brought defamation claims from
everybody from the covington kids
to anybody that's been politically
targeted for the wrong purposes
currently suing don lemon over some of
his behavior
so not afraid there's lawyers out there
that will be willing to represent you
and justify your cause
but that doesn't mean you have to be a
hero do what makes the most sense for
you
and figure out the best way you can both
assert your independence
care about what you care about and still
protect what
matters most to you and sometimes that
means protect your job if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversation about law instead of the
non-stop yelling you get everywhere else
check out our law playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell